it is right to save humanity it is wrong
to pollute this earth in the sequel to
his oscar-winning documentary Al Gore
picks up where he left off we see his
efforts to push through the Paris
climate change deal and president
Trump's decision to pull out that
includes a promise to cancel billions in
climate change spending but a decade on
from his first film the former vice
president insists there is cause for
hope we see it with the incredible drop
in the prices of renewable energy from
the Sun and the wind electric vehicles
we're seeing a sustainability revolution
around the world now that's quite
dramatic and I think we are going to
solve this crisis early talks between
the former vice president and the then
president-elect had seemed hopeful I
found it an extremely interesting
conversation and to be continued but it
wasn't to be our withdrawal from the
agreement represents a reassertion of
America's sovereignty
it's that dialogue now closed iru still
sort of making approaches to no I've had
no further conversations with him since
his announcement I did have a reason to
believe he would stay in I thought he
would come to his senses but I was wrong
does it seem unlikely that there will be
any u-turn on this I wouldn't hold my
breath I think that he's thrown his lot
in with the climate deniers he's
selected a rogue's gallery of deniers to
surround him some in his inner circle do
have good sense on this but they've been
shouted down by the climate deniers goal
remains a polarizing figure loved by
climate concern Democrats in America
loathed by many of President Trump's
Republican hardliners a hundred years
ago a famous journalist in America Upton
Sinclair wrote it's difficult to get a
man to understand something if his
income depends upon him not
understanding it and if you substitute
campaign contributions and lobbying
expenditures for income that
is the explanation for why some are
highly resistant to change the film
tries to separate out the science if
politicians are dragging their heels
Al Gore argues it's times that people
shout louder
Katie Spencer skyknight